foreign
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving in storage Studio it's the Ramsey
show where America hangs out to have a
conversation about your life your
marriage your money your work everything
whatever's going on in your life give us
a shout at AAA
825-5225 I'm John deloney joined here by
best-selling author and good friend
Rachel Cruz and we're taking your calls
on just about everything that's going on
in your life we have a packed audience
out here today it's good to see
everybody and by pack there's like 12
people and most of them are the child's
family so that makes my heart feel good
nice and warm it's good to see everybody
um all right let's go to Sarah in
Pensacola Florida what is let's hear
what's up what's up Sarah
hey thanks so much for taking my call
I'm really excited to talk to you guys
today thank you so much what's up
my question revolves around a parent
meeting financial assistance
um but there's also some emotional and
psychological stuff going on as well so
how did my husband and I generously care
for my parents and help them financially
as the Bible commands while also not
supporting or playing into a lack of
planning and action on their part to
improve their situation
okay Sarah tell me a little bit more
about their situation are they are they
are they are they really struggling or
they're just making different decisions
than what you would make
both so
both deaf definitely yeah
um I I'm gonna try to keep it real big
picture here so
um they are on a fixed income
um and don't have like any savings in
place um but there's definitely some
things that they've done over the years
to put them in that position okay
um whereas my husband and I we are the
opposite we are big planners um we
follow the Ramsey plan paid our house
off last year we're debt free
um so it's kind of battling approaches
to finances
um and so over the years we've tried to
help in different ways but now my parent
is in the situation where they are
um more frequently asking for financial
assistance for things okay so they're
coming to you guys and asking for money
okay right and it's increasing in
quantity and
um amount and so I really want to help
them and I want to honor them
um I know that the Bible commands for us
to do that but yeah the bank account yes
sir honor does not mean you give
somebody whatever they want whenever
they want it that's not what honoring
means in fact sometimes the best way I
can honor my kids is to say no and they
want to go get donuts again
right right and to say no because now
I'm in a position to
um love you and honor you enough
that I won't participate in you hurting
yourself further
and like my kids will do they'll kick
and scream and be upset and like our
aging parents can do sometimes they can
get all upset and that's they are
welcome to to do that I'm not going to
hold that in my soul
um but I'm gonna sit down and say Here's
here is if I'm gonna give you money here
is
um
it's my money so I have a choice my wife
and I my husband I have a choice and how
we're gonna spend our money and so
here's the stipulations for our money
and if you don't want the stipulations
that is fantastic you're grown-ups but
that's the only way this money leaves us
and you said you tried to help him over
the years I think it's important this is
hard
um
parents
you can only help your parents if they
ask for it
when kids start trying to like tell
their parents what they should be doing
with any any number of things it never
works out right you know what I mean I
don't want Mike the other day my son was
telling me how to do something and I
finally just stopped and said I'm old I
know how to do this like I'm an old man
I know how to and he was like well you
know and I was like trust me dude I know
and so anyway
um I think you need to be invited into
the advice conversation so have you sat
down and said
um we are scared for what comes next for
y'all what is the plan have y'all had
that conversation
multiple times okay and what's the
response ah we don't need nothing
um most recently I think we've gotten to
the point where they're very open about
their approach and we are open on our
approach and we came to a verbal
agreement that we needed to find a
middle ground here because staying on
our opposite sides was not working I oh
wait wait hold on go ahead well no I was
going to say I don't tell me what do you
mean we need to find a middle ground can
you not just believe what you believe
and they believe why what's the what's
the middle ground is it because
conversation was getting heated
with conflict or was it what was that
they get very emotional kind of just
start breaking down and then we can't
continue the conversation so but that's
my that's a choice that they are making
that's a manipulation that's a way to
get you to do things
yeah a middle ground you don't you don't
need to come to a middle ground when it
comes to bending on your values and what
you think is important and what you and
your husband have put forth as the way
we're going to handle money there's not
a middle ground there
there is a here is our if you would like
our money here's our values and if you
all want to kick and scream and yell and
get upset you are welcome to do that you
can do it in our home because we don't
talk like that with it with each other
but you're welcome to not answer our
phone calls and be mad and think we're
terrible kids
we love you too much
yeah it's very hard to set those down it
is it is and that's where all of this
right now all of your focus is how do I
deal with them
Rachel I want to shift it to you Sarah
how do you and your husband make peace
with these are our values how do you and
your husband make peace with when Mom
and Dad get mad throw a temper tantrum
tell us we're the worst kids ever what
do we do how do we circle around each
other and move forward and what's hard
Sarah though is every person right
especially when you're dealing with your
parent you Resort back Sarah to that
six-year-old girl right instantly you go
back to who you were because it's that
relationship it's your parents and you
and you have to be grown up Sarah in
that situation you have to look at
yourself and say I have to take care of
that little girl that's there that is
scared of her parents and kind of is
like oof but you also have to be able to
say okay I'm a grown adult and my
husband and I have created a family we
have done this and there's a confidence
there Sarah that you guys have you've
literally done the steps you've done it
you've gotten the results you've wanted
and that's enough to stand on to be able
to say hey this is our values and this
is what we believe but that's what's so
hard about the parent-child relationship
I think is because we can Resort back to
like our bodies go there like that yeah
and Sarah
let me tell you this it it's unfair to
put a kid in a position
to be responsible for the emotional
regulation of the adults in their in
their world
and so if you grew up in a house where
you had to make sure Dad didn't get too
mad or you had to make sure Mom doesn't
cry because now we're all gonna go down
I'm sorry that they put you in that
position that wasn't fair you were a kid
and that was too heavy of a burden for
you to carry it wasn't your job it was
the adult's job to not throw temper
tantrums to not get upset to be able to
emotionally regulate themselves and it
sounds like that is carried over into
your adult life and I want to tell you
now as an adult that's not your job your
job is to treat him with dignity and
with respect and with kindness and not
participate in them further hurting them
and setting boundaries is not
dishonoring your parents absolutely not
change the language of that because
that's just not true that's right and
I'll repeat that
honoring somebody does not mean you give
them whatever they want whatever they
want so parents are like you need to
honor your parents and give me that's
not how that works that's not what the
word honor means honor means I will love
you even when it's hard and it's hard to
say no your parents your parents are
lucky to have you Sarah
um you and your husband to get away get
some firm values and some firm
boundaries and then you start practicing
setting them forward
we'll be right back on the Ramsey Show
[Music]
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees ever to
bring things back by their 100 percent
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free see why blinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings visit blinds.com to
save up to 40 percent off everything
site-wide go to blinds.com for more
information
[Music]
this is the Ramsey Show give us a shout
at triple eight eight two five five two
two five I'm John deloney joined here by
Rachel Cruz
best-selling author one of the greatest
people who's ever lived let's go out to
Taylor in Fort Wayne Indiana what's up
Taylor
awesome how are you
oh doing great just money stuff you know
just money stuff what's up yeah so I'm a
baby step number two
um all of that debt that I have is
solely student loans and I'm currently
in the grace period of the student loans
I think it should be called the disgrace
period whoa yeah honestly you know what
we should call that's fair that's fair
Taylor how much do you owe
um so I've been working on it I started
with 94 I'm down to 84 000. so I'm
working really hard yeah but um my
question is if the most effective way to
tackle this grace period so um these
past few months I've been tackling it as
if I'm in repayment so I'm making those
projected minimum monthly payments on
all of them and then tackling
um you know my target but I'm wondering
there is that flexibility in the grace
period should I be taking that like
extra 800 and just absolutely
annihilating my target or just keep with
the path of the minimum sleep payments
and then throwing the extra at my target
what's your target
her heart starts beating faster
oh sorry
Snowball right now is what I'm doing and
the one that is like getting all the
extra money thrown at it at that time is
what I'm referring to as my target does
that make sense yeah so how many you so
your student loan out of the 84 how many
separate loans are there
oh gosh well then you break it down
between Federal and private so I I'm
using the federal
um stuff going on right now to my
advantage I'm just I'm putting on the
back burner because it's got that zero
percent interest right now so my private
loans are getting all my financial
attention right now
um so I've been focusing on them and I
am down to I'm down to six of them six
private loans and then how many federal
yeah is it just the one
just a lot of little guys yeah like one
two three four five six seven eight nine
like nine little ones like one to two
thousand but they're all they're all
like four percent and with when they do
come back and start you know adding up
or whatever but since we're at zero
percent right now I've decided to just
focus on like my 10 to 13 interest
loans yeah still working the snowball
within my private if that makes sense no
it does no it absolutely does so I I
underst I understand what you're saying
um I would look at two things Taylor
number one I student loans is the one
type of debt we're okay with you
consolidating and it feels like you're
there's a lot to keep up with here I
mean you're making I mean 15 different
payments a month to continue you know
the middle I mean like there's a lot
going on so I would look to see is there
a way
um
you know again look at the option and
see okay if I Consolidated some of these
into a lower interest rate that may just
make it more simplistic through it but I
still tailor even though private versus
public and I hear what you're saying
about the interest rate I would still be
knocking out those smaller ones because
you said there's like one that's a
thousand dollars here there I'm like
just go ahead and get those out of the
way and get that momentum going
um as you continue to pay the minimum
payments on everything else how much do
you make a year
um about 50 okay how old are you fifty
thousand uh 24 24 okay what do you do
for a living
I'm a speech therapist oh way to go good
for you
um and that's a great job tailored to do
private uh sessions with kids and you
know do other things I would I if I were
you I would be making extra income using
your degree because you can make a lot
doing some stuff you know maybe a few
nights a week right
um and up that 50 because it'll take a
while to knock out that 84 with just
making the 50. so I I commend you on you
know you've knocked out 10 which is
incredible and you're doing exactly what
in a sense what you should be doing and
I hear
um you know you're organized you're
doing this you're excited about it
there's there's definitely that
enthusiasm
that I could hear uh in your voice but I
would still pay off that smallest
interest rate and I would be working
extra get that 50 up for a period of
time and and knock this out
okay so still just make them just act as
if it's in repayment essentially just
make all the minimums and just kind of
keep doing what I'm doing okay like the
old school like the
the baby steps as they're intended to
snowball like put all 15 of those loans
in order of smallest to largest
put a piece of tape over their interest
interest uh like what the interest
you're paying on them and every
Financial
Fancy Pants listening to this and every
Instagram influencer is like it's so
stupid bro you're just leaving money on
the to end this isn't a money game it's
a psychology game and I would love for
you to look up in five months and have
four to six of those loans knocked out
and you think you're getting ahead
because you're paying 13 against five
percent and that feels right
mathematically actually it is right
mathematically okay you're right on the
math but we've just done this so long
the psychology doesn't work you get
tired and then you're gonna need a new
car and then you're gonna need it right
and so you're just gonna run into stuff
and just just hit the gas pedal on these
things and Rachel said she's dead on me
get another job get two jobs work extra
let's make this a 24 month project and
just be done forever be 26 not only but
anything
for sure is that cool
that is cool yep thank you guys you're
doing great Taylor yeah thank you for
being a speech path too that's a tough
tough gig all right let's go to a Logan
in Hartford Connecticut what's up Logan
are you there brother
nope all right let's go on to let's go
to Laura in Raleigh what's up Laura
let's be quiet hey Laura hey how are you
today hey can you hear me I'm not gonna
be quiet
I appreciate that so much I've heard
those words I said that eight times
today you be quiet my whole life yeah
what's up well I have four boys and so
there's very little of that quiet in my
house you did it without swear words
that's incredible yes congratulations so
uh how can we help
okay so I need your help because
I do not know how to budget my money
um my husband has done a great job of
providing for our family
he worked at a wonderful job for 10
years and was let go in 2018
and since then he has been working on
the project
where he wants to develop a golf aid for
golfers and so he's been working on that
can I can I interject here
yeah so he got let go in 2018 and he's
had a big idea for about five years five
years and has made no money and probably
put you on a hole
yes so well no we're not in a hole yet
but that's why I'm calling to prevent
that getting close okay yeah so he like
I said we had we had quite a bit of
money in savings and we've been living
off of that oh yeah um he has
successfully started a company before
and it's a wonderful company y'all have
probably heard of it
um but I won't mention it but anyway
um he's trying to do it again and we
have about eighty thousand dollars left
and he I every time I ask him I'm like
can you he's I'm the sender he's the
favor and so when we have Financial
discussions it usually goes something
like this Laura you need to stop
spending money and I'm like well I can't
because we have a family so give me a
budget he's like well just don't spend
money where we don't need to and I have
you said how about you make some
foreign
it's been five years Laura I know I know
we did have we did have a financial
conversation two weeks ago and they told
him if by June this hasn't taken off
then I want you to get a job or I want
to sell our home so we have
um we bought our house back in 20. okay
hey Laura do this this is uh this is too
important of a call because too many
people are experiencing this across the
country so I'm gonna hold you over
through the break hang on the line here
and then we're gonna bring you back and
Rachel and I are going to dig into this
with you because there's a lot here this
is bigger than a money conversation this
has to do with you being terrified that
your husband's gonna continue this so
hang on the line here we'll be right
back right here on the Ramsey Show
[Music]
foreign
look I love real estate and I want you
to have a house but I don't want a house
to have you that's why you need to get
in touch with Churchill Mortgage to make
sure you do this right these guys are
awesome they'll help you get on a
smarter mortgage plan because they're
committed to doing what's right for you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice basically they care
that's why we call them Ramsey trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and Churchill is here to help go to
their site churchillmortgage.com Ramsey
to start your approval or get more
information
[Music]
by Rachel Cruz and we are taking calls
of money and life and marriage
whatever's going on Triple eight eight
two five five two two five and we're
gonna go back to Laura in Raleigh North
Carolina Lori there
yeah hey all right so I'm gonna run back
through your uh what's going on and we
can start here and let me know if I'm
missing something
um you and your husband had a great job
things were awesome y'all were cruising
along and then he got laid off in 2018
and he's an entrepreneur he's built a
really successful business before and he
had another great idea to help golfers
um and
I think golfers need a lot of help but
that's a whole other conversation and so
he decided he's going to help golfers
and then we look up and it's 2023 the
business isn't making money y'all have
basically
set fire to your savings and now there's
starting to be some the the there's some
tension in the home
pressure yeah we are
conversations are turning into hey you
need to quit spending money him to you
right yeah and you'll have 80 grand left
yeah what is he what does he bring in a
year
uh so nothing literally nothing it's
literally nothing 10 20 so he got a
large severance package and that was
2018 2019 and then
um nothing's in Spanish nothing nothing
nothing
so we had a large large savings and we
have no debt aside from our mortgage
what Charles living expenses Laura if
you if you said okay you know we spend
how much a year if yeah if you could
estimate a year oh gosh
probably 120 maybe 100 like yeah this is
this is embarrassing because I am the
sender and I'm just like I don't know
how much I spend because if we need it I
buy it
um and that yeah yeah and that's how you
guys have been functioning yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah
I right before we went to the break I
said this isn't a money issue there's
something way deeper here
um
I'm gonna be super honest okay is that
cool
I'm worried about the future of y'alls
I'm worried about the future of y'all's
marriage
here's why
I think that if you were to be really
honest with yourself you're losing
respect for your husband or it's gonna
start rolling into from frustration
to I'm just going to live my life and
he'll tell me to you're going to end up
in resentment and relational resentment
is really tough to come back from that's
the ash
and he on the other hand is going to
wrap himself up in shame his thing's not
working he's got another deal and then
maybe another deal I just need this one
thing to come through and all of a
sudden he looks up and it's been five
years and he's gonna tighten the control
up and that's going to come out on you
and he's going to resent his crazy
spinning wife who just doesn't
understand he just needs one more break
and you see what I'm saying and you all
start living separate lives in the same
home and I've said it you end up two
inches apart but two thousand miles away
from each other and that's a recipe for
a whole lot of issues
is that fair I've listened to your story
before and
um
listen to your radio show before and
there have been many times where I've
been like yep that's us yeah
um and so I am I I am trying though and
so absolutely absolutely I did I well I
I did put boundaries in place I may need
to adjust those boundaries he is
um he did acquiesce to my
boundary of getting a job by June
um but
I think my
my main question is like where do we go
from here we have this house we have
about 415 approximately because I don't
know how much it would sell for if we
could sell it but we have 415 in equity
in the house we own but it's not a it's
not a house price you're trying to solve
a math problem yeah it's not a house
problem it's an income problem I mean
that's what it is and so the house isn't
the thing that that is you know out of
whack I mean obviously you guys have a
mortgage and so you're like oh I have to
actually pay the mortgage and we don't
have you know the money is coming out of
savings and so you know on a tactical
level Laura not just the relational
because that's kind of what John was
hitting on
on a tactical level I'm going to give
you uh Financial Peace University for a
year and every dollar and I want you
guys to sit down together and I think
actually seeing numbers and go back and
pull grocery numbers from the last three
months restaurants like everything you
spend money on because there is this
level of I don't really know and that
fear starts to magnify when you don't
have logic John always says facts are
your friends so I think just even just
for today just a practical step when it
comes to the money piece is for you and
I would say you to do it
um to do the budget first and then you
guys sit down and look at it but I think
that's going to give you a guiding post
because you're able to say okay we spend
uh ten thousand dollars we need ten
thousand dollars a month to keep our
lifestyle without dipping into savings
how do we solve that problem right you
can tactically start you know hitting
that which is going to give you a level
of Peace because you are terrified right
I mean and anyone would Laura I mean
what you've watched savings time for you
for the last five years so so you're not
crazy you're not you're not this like oh
I'm over the top dramatic no this is
this is real life you have four boys you
know you're a mom and you're looking at
grocery bills and all of it and so
you're and you've been doing that on
your own as well which is what it sounds
like and so he needs to see the numbers
realistically of of what is going on
because this whole idea of oh you just
can't you know just stop spending and
you're like no literally there's like a
sports fee for him to place out like I
have to pay that like there are things
yeah like there are actual things that I
have to spend and I want him to see
these numbers because you've been on an
island Laura in a lot of different ways
emotionally in lots of ways but
financially you have been and so I want
to bring him in uh to that conversation
and you guys start and I want you guys
to go through Financial Peace University
together I think it's just a great
springboard it's getting you on the same
page when it comes to the money piece
and what's wild and I don't know which
comes first the chicken or the egg John
but we hear people all the time say gosh
we started working together with our
money and suddenly our marriage improved
for some people they're like no we
needed our marriage to improve and then
we worked on the money together right I
I don't know which one's first I don't
even know if there's a truth that's kind
of like that chicken or egg thing
um but they both are so deeply
intertwined
um so let me tell you how I would enter
this conversation if I'm you Laura I
this is I I would put the you have to
get a job by June
that is a tactic that comes later
the first conversation is sitting down
and saying we need to have a hard
conversation and you look at him and say
I'm scared to death and I can't breathe
I think the problem is that I'm not
scared because I know I know that's
going to sound crazy I grew up without a
lot and so I feel like it would not be
the worst thing in the world for me I
actually think it'd be a little good for
our boys to learn less entitlement like
our boys live in a big house
have a lot of things and they just think
that that's how life goes and I'm like
no you don't understand like okay those
are boundaries Laura you can put in
place as a parent regardless of your
financial situation it doesn't need to
be out of the desperation don't use your
voice don't use your kids
as an excuse to tell your husband you
want to move
don't do that don't use your kids as an
excuse to tell your husband I don't
respect you anymore Jim had a job in
five years and a common trap with
entrepreneurs especially ones that are
successful right out of the gate is
they're really good at the thing they
did that they sell and it becomes really
good and they think that they're good at
building businesses they may have just
been really good at Plumbing or they may
have been really good at selling online
whatever and it doesn't translate all
the time and you get stuck like you're
spinning your tires in the mud right and
so you might not be scared
but you're losing faith in this guy yeah
I think that I think
I think yeah John I think you're right I
it's more fear for my relationship than
it is for the money and the house and
all the stuff I'm like I want to be
you want to be married there you go in
five years Laura that's where you
started I want to be married that's
where you start
not with you got to get a job not your
lazy bum and not it is I want to be
married to you in five years and I think
that the foundation underneath this is
cracking underneath
and I love you too much hang on the line
here uh Rachel we're gonna give you the
tools that that can help keep you guys
afloat and put you all on the same page
but you both got to be vulnerable and
start there okay Laura hang on the line
and uh General get you taken care of
we'll be right back right here on the
Ramsay show
[Music]
yo yo hey if you're a new listener and
you want to dive deeper into the Ramsay
baby steps go to ramsaysolutions.com and
click on the get started button we'll
help you figure out the best next step
for your financial Journey based on
exactly where you are today sometimes
we're talking through the show and
people like Ah that's not really my
situation go to ramseysolutions.com and
click on get started and it will it will
line up with exactly where you are
ramsesolutions.com click get started all
right let's go to Anthony in Davenport
what's up Anthony how we doing hey John
and Rachel how are you guys doing today
great what's happening Brother how can
we help yo hey hey so I'm calling to see
if my wife and I should pay off our
mortgage yes here's our situation we're
all about 160 uh K on our house and we
have about 115 in the savings account
with another 27 in a checking account
and then another about 25 in a joint
account that we can pull out and have
access to at any time
um so I was just calling to see if that
I guess that would leave us with about
8K and savings
um he's going to see if that's a good
move or if we just you know build up our
savings a little bit yeah how much do
you guys make a year Anthony
um so last year was about
170k 170 175k okay okay
um do you know off the top of your head
what your expenses would be three to six
months
um yeah that like
8K would be about
close to it'd probably be three or four
months
but then we also do have a nine month
old son at home so I didn't know if that
changes anything
uh yeah I mean you know I would I would
lean whenever kids are in the picture I
like to lean the six month rule just to
like because you have it and there's
there's there's no we want you to pay
off your house
but there's no point in draining
absolutely everything in order to do it
right we want to be wise about it um but
if you're getting a check for fourteen
thousand dollars
February 1st or February 15th is that
right
uh
you're talking hey talking like a tax
return or no I'm saying like if you make
175 Grand your take home is gonna be
what about 14. no I take it would be
about 11 right
yeah yeah we're probably be a little bit
shy of that this month okay so if you
went down to 8 000 or you just wait till
February 1st or February 15th and you
get down to eight you're gonna turn
around and get a check for 11 and you're
gonna spend two to three to four of that
for the month and you're you're right
back up to your four to five to six
months emergency fund right okay
yeah yep
so yeah okay so so you guys are just
saying hey hang on for a couple wrong
what did you do just to be on the safe
side
I mean I would probably wait through
February 15th but then yeah I mean I
would cash out that joint and then take
yeah what's ever left of that that 15
drain a little bit of the checking and
that's that's the thing I would do is I
would get rid of the 27 I'd get rid of
the 25 I would take the 115 account and
probably take 195 out of it until I had
20 grand left and then wait till that
next check comes back in that's what
that's what probably what I do because I
I man
here's what it feels like at this moment
you ever driving down the highway and
you really have to go to the bathroom
and your body just kind of settles into
like that dull ache like I gotta go and
then you see a gas station and you exit
and then all of a sudden it's like
rockets like I gotta go net you know
what I mean like it gets so the urgency
is so raw
um that's where you are right now you've
got this money you realize how close we
are and now it's like I gotta go Gotta
Go Gotta Go and Rachel's Rachel's call
to wisdom is important we just talked to
too many people that
pay it all off and then all of a sudden
their car explodes next month and they
got a nine month old and now they're in
a mess
um but I do love the idea of you just
taking a big chunk
yep you got 10 grand left on your on
your mortgage and you've got 20 000
bucks in the bank and the next month you
get a check for 11 Grand and you're debt
free
okay that makes sense
that's how I would do it in my house so
Anthony well done yeah congratulations
man that's incredible yeah thank you
guys we appreciate it congratulations
that's so really really really great
um about this time of year
we get flooded with calls because
everyone's looking for a fresh start
with their money
we saw record
um expenses during Christmas and now we
are seeing record balances on personal
credit card accounts and that leads me
to believe Rachel that people put things
on their credit card not to survive
not because inflation things are
expensive but to prop up a lifestyle
this is the way we live this is who we
are this is what our Christmas looks
like and I'm just gonna put on credit
cards then and now we got hell to pay
and so if that's you you can't just wish
for things to change and expect it to
happen
um you've got to do some different
things with your money and you've got to
have a plan and we teach you that plan
in Financial Peace University this is
the course that will help you rethink
how you manage money you'll learn our
proven plan to beat debt build wealth
plus you'll have our financial coaches
to help you every step of the way and
that's really important people often say
I can't get through on the show so we we
hired Financial coaches that will help
you nearly 10 million people million
people have taken FPU followed this plan
and changed their lives you can do it
too and today is the perfect time to
start right now we're offering FPU we're
doing anti-inflation
um 69.99 but only through the end of the
month that is almost half off it's super
cheap
69.99 for FPU this year you can have
more peace in your finances in your life
don't wait to do this get this limited
time offer on FPU ramseysolutions.com
deal d-e-a-l that's ramseysolutions.com
slash deal
all right let's run to Nick in New York
City what's up Nick we're right up
against the clock so go as quick as you
can get to your question what's up
area I'm 24 years old making 150 000
pre-taxed I worked for one of the major
Tech times that just laid off about 18
000 people I'm currently being recruited
for a similar role at a large bank for a
rough total of about two hundred
thousand dollars compensation and in
short my question is whether or not I
should continue pursuing that role or
other roles that are similar given the
current Tech economy as that other
companies done 1100 layoffs
the which companies in 1100 you you said
yours did 18.
yeah so my current company has done
about 18 000 layoffs yeah and the
company that I'm being recruited for has
done 1100. oh I got you I gotcha
um what do you enjoy Nick what's your uh
you love the banking world you love the
tech world
um so they're both technology rules uh
within either I guess you can call it
warehousing or uh banking I'm passionate
about both I think my current role is
somewhat safe because I own two large
platforms but I often feel like I'm
doing the job of about three to four
people which uh provide some degree of
safety but also makes me feel frequently
overworked I mean it's kind of one of
the reasons I'm looking for a new role
as well so I'm kind of trying to
understand whether or not I should give
up that feeling of security uh to pursue
new opportunities in general given the
landscape as a whole well the I don't
think you're gonna have infinite
security because the field you are in is
being shaken around like a snow globe
right now right so that's that's the
nature of that season right now right
you're a farmer and it has been raining
for years and suddenly there's a drought
that's where you are okay
um if you're telling me that you can
make an additional 50 Grand and
guaranteed salary stay in the current
place where you live and a company did
smaller layoffs but they have their eyes
on you
I would sit down with that company and
say can we sign on three years
like and I would be really open because
you're you're negotiating from a period
of a position of strength which is you
just laid off 1800 people I survived the
big 18 000 layoff at my place they want
me there I'm nervous to come over I want
to be a part of what y'all are doing but
I'm nervous to come over and then just
turn on get laid off right when I right
get there what what guarantees do you
have how safe is that right so I would
just be really direct and open because
you can be because if they say no you go
oh man and then you have 150 000 job you
can fall back on
okay that makes a lot of sense
um thank you here's the deal don't try
to avoid the discomfort right now you're
in a volatile
industry right now
I would try to
um utilize your strengths get as good as
you possibly can seek to get some more
credentials make yourself bulletproof in
this season right because there is a lot
of layoffs but Tech's not going away man
it's not going anywhere hey this has
been the first hour of the Ramsay show
we'll be right back give us a shout
triple eight eight two five five two two
five this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
foreign
if you love the show and want a deeper
dive on your money Journey we have a
Weekly Newsletter that gives you
trending and helpful articles and tips
on following the Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
foreign
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsey show where America hangs out to
have a conversation about your money and
your marriage and your work and your
life I'm Dr John deloney joined here by
Rachel Cruz best-selling author and
great human being we're taking a call to
really just about anything
um the call is toll-free and that's
about what the advice is worth but we're
here for you triple eight eight two five
five two two five triple eight eight two
five five two two five all right let's
go to the question of the day Rachel
today's question comes from Samuel in
Georgia yes so Samuel says we just
bought a 330 000 house knowing it needed
some updating we got quotes for a 2
hundred thousand dollar remodel if we
did an addition and updated every inch
of the house inside and out we have a
hundred and eighty thousand dollars in
the bank currently but have a family
member willing to give us a fifty
thousand dollar loan interest free our
income is roughly sixty eight hundred
dollars a month if we budget and don't
spend money on anything on on anything
outside of bills and groceries our
expenses would be around five thousand a
month I don't feel good about spending
that much but just curious what you guys
think about an interest-free loan
helping make it a dream home what a nice
little spin there at the end
so good
buddy let's hug Samuel okay uh just
short answers and they'll know yeah no I
mean like I understand math
mathematically you're like oh there's no
interest this seems like a good deal
but when you involve debt period into
your life it changes the equation and
then on top of that it's not a bank
you're borrowing from some big building
it's a family member which honestly
feels like it feels worse oh dude
because every every
dinner every Sunday afternoon dinner
every time that he's gonna look over and
be like first he took my daughter and
now he took me fifty thousand dollars or
you're gonna buy a new rake and he's
gonna be like I know that's it oh huh I
thought you were gonna pay me my money
back I would owe me some money and it's
like yeah that he's your bank then
whoever the family member is I got a new
opportunity to take a job a new job
um you need to stay where you are I need
to get you I need to pay that hey dude
it's just and even with like no there
should be no strings attached you just
do your thing it it rarely don't don't
don't don't so so I would not say no so
if I were you guys you're saying it
would be an addition and updating every
inch of that so pull back the bid I mean
I would say okay let's just do the
downstairs for now maybe one or two
bathrooms upstairs which won't be 200
000 maybe a hundred thousand and you
have that in the bank go ahead and start
it and do a little bit at a time or wait
and save up until you guys have the cash
which which is going to be months from
now
um and do it then but no I would not
take the loan I would go at the speed of
cash when you guys have the cash to do
it and just
I'd say simmer down Samuel you know I
feel like our there's this lifestyle
this this lifestyle level that everyone
expects to have
and it's not necessary and we sacrifice
our mental health John our sleep at
night our peace to go and just acquire
stuff in the name of just having that
new house
and when you drain your account when you
go into debt for this kind of stuff it's
it's not worth the trade-off right just
to have stuff and then you're stressed
and you're having to go to a job that
you hate to pay the bills I mean all of
it so we were just talking uh off air
uh and Winston was in here earlier and
Winston is I've been talking to him
about a particular truck that I was into
and he likes the same kind of truck and
we were talking about it talking about
it and my wife and I made an agreement
that if we hit a financial Milestone at
Christmas that I the next big purchase
for us would be get me a car finally I
got my car it's not great
and I found myself getting insane like I
was waking up in the morning and I was
scrolling the things and I was emailing
guys hey can you see if you can find
this and I was checking with Winston and
he's like dude just be a grown grown up
and get the like and then I realized is
this fervor is the absolute worst time
to buy anything so I just stopped and he
just came out and goes hey did you get
the truck and I was like I'm just
waiting at least a month probably two
maybe even four or five and when I when
I did that everything went my anxiety
left I just it was it was just it was
just chill out
I'm only going to make purchases
especially like this of a new truck
which evidently they're pressed in
Platinum and gold they're so expensive
um or a hundred or two hundred thousand
dollar remodel only do that when you can
just pop right down in bed at night and
go right to sleep yes all right yes yes
if you owe your father-in-law or
mother-in-law or dad or Uncle money
I'm telling you you're not gonna sleep
man no matter how good they say the
interest is you're just not yep that's
right that's right so so Samuel nope
move at the speed of cash take your time
you're okay everything's fine uh there's
no rush in this no one's making you do
this either you know what I I know we
need to move on but
I really like what you just said about
do one bathroom at a time or just do the
downstairs
I bet you as you get into this project
what you want to do to that house will
change yeah and it will morph and oh
y'all did this so so what if we and if
you do it as you as you do if you pay
for project by project they're going to
tell you it'd be way cheaper if you just
did all right now fine then I'll find
somebody else who will meet this bid
they'll take care of it but I like the
idea of doing it project by project
um instead of just getting mowed down
your whole house and basically yeah and
if you said you know I had a I have a
million bucks can I take 200 and go I'm
like yeah go oh you know what I mean
like it's all it's about the math it's
the money here and so the ratios yeah
it's just not worth it not worth it
right now all right let's go to Melissa
and San Luis Obispo what's up let's see
here do we have
um
all right let's do it let's uh Melissa
what's up this is or right up against
the clock so get right to your question
a few jobs aggressively
auto accident totaling my vehicle 21
000 in yeah I'll receive 21 000 in
settlement this coming week um and my
question is in purchasing a new vehicle
does it make sense to spin that
settlement amount invest more money from
my emergency fund or spend less money
um in order to put some of that
settlement amount towards my student
loans great question how much student
loans do you have left
five eighty thousand remaining and
currently under interest-free
forbearance when the interest uh begins
again my rates are anywhere from 4.5 to
7.5 percent okay uh for the past year
I've been making payments of 3 000 or
more per month good for you how much do
you make a year
I make a hundred thousand in my
full-time job and approximately 20 000 a
year in my weekend side hustle good for
you can I ask you a question Melissa
yes you know what you want to do what do
you want to do
there's a party oh about 500 Miles twice
a month
um and my hobbies are mountain
activities in which four-wheel drive is
necessary I lean towards spending the
entire 21 000 again on another reliable
fund vehicle
um or even investing maybe up to 5 000
more but I'm not sure which will bring
me more long-term happiness okay
you're gonna hate what I'm about to say
Melissa
yeah you ready you're broke you owe
eighty thousand dollars to the
government
if I were you I would spend five
thousand dollars on a good Camry or
Honda Accord and I would put the rest of
that money towards my debt and I would
use that as a incentive jet fuel to pay
that stuff off as quick as possible so I
can get the car that I actually want to
live the life I actually want to live
right now you can't live the life you
want because you owe the government
money knock it out knock it out knock it
out we'll be right back on the Ramsey
Show
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
with health care costs Rising learn how
Christian Healthcare Ministries can help
you make the most out of your budget
visit
chministries.org budget don't worry it's
worth it
foreign
[Music]
hey what's up this is the Ramsey Show
I'm John deloney joined here by Rachel
Cruz triple eight eight two five a five
two two five taking your calls on money
and on life let's go out to Abby in
Omaha what's up Abby
hello John and Rachel how are you I'm
remarkable how are you
great thank you I just had a quick tax
question
um my
my
um uh a Roth IRA that he had from a
previous job last year and we are
working baby step number two we just
bought FPU
um and so we have money and savings but
we are trying to figure out what the
best plan is of do we use that money
that we have in savings could go ahead
and just
you know push us forward on our snowball
or do we hold on to it and just kind of
see
um for a couple months and see what what
could happen with our taxes how much did
you guys prefer kind of I'm coming how
much did you guys pull out
of the Roth uh he pulled 50. why you
can't sing he he did this why did you do
that yes he did
um well he was kind of concerned about
you know the crash and losing it so he
initially rolled that into a gold Roth
iron
oh the gold what a box of farts on a
stick what that's like yeah I can't
believe he did we usually get attacked
we usually get a tax refund back
um
how much do you guys make a year but I
know
um combined it's about 140. Okay so
listen you need to have a hard
conversation with him and just look him
in the eye hold both of his hands put
YouTube down
put the internets down take his phone
away many discussions yeah I was a topic
of many discussions so but it was I I
say he because
um we agree to disagree I guess so but I
just now you didn't understand that it's
all coming down Abby Abby I did it's all
coming down he's being facetious I'm
just being an idiot that's okay I I
totally understand like
you know his desire to be prepared and
we have two little kids at home and so
he just wanted to make sure that we were
going to how much you guys have been
savings Abby how much do you guys
haven't said 20 000 okay 20.
so it's it's like okay well we usually
get a tax refund back I'm expecting to
have to pay in I'm not really sure how
much that's going to be he wants to wait
and hold on to what we have in savings
until we see how much we have to pay in
I want to put like half of that down and
kind of how much debts do you guys have
um right now about 85 what's it in
um various things small personal loans
credit cards in one vehicle okay
I mean yeah you could get with it with a
tax professional and look and see okay
what's you know what are the taxes we're
gonna owe in their tax bracket what are
the fees associated with this right and
kind of get that that estimate I mean
you're going to know here soon of what
of what you're gonna owe so yeah you
don't want to I would not recommend
taking this 20 and just throwing it at
the debt right now I want you to have an
emergency fund and IRS when it comes to
um paying the government that's that's
that's top right so that knowing right
that you're going to have that tax bill
coming up uh is huge so so yeah if you
guys can get any kind of estimate on
what your refund is going to be what the
taxes will be on the on taking this out
um and then kind of look and see okay
um you can make a move from there or you
can pause save up a bunch and when you
guys kind of clear tax season then go
and throw the rest at your debts and I
want to
there's a there's some wisdom underneath
what Rachel is saying and I want to make
sure you you get it because you need it
your husband needs it all of us need it
okay back in 2010 when the market was
bananas and I was not well I was an
anxious anxious mess I was like a
beautiful mind I'd come up with all
these spreadsheets about how the next
housing market was going to collapse
they're gonna have to nationalize houses
it was gonna be a big thing I had this
whole thing lined up
yeah and before I I had a whole plan I
was going to cash out all my retirement
I was going to take the hit I was gonna
do this I was gonna do this I was gonna
do this and thankfully
I went and sat with a buddy who worked
at a bank and then I sat with another
buddy who was admittedly I was I was
privileged to have this relationship but
he was a close friend but he was the CFO
of a large company I walked through my
whole crazy plan and both of them said
I'm not certain about what you're doing
here and they're just being gentle with
me but they said don't cash out anything
whatever you do don't do that and I
listened to him because they had this
thing that I didn't have which was
information and wisdom and I'll tell you
you're you're struggling with the tax I
don't know we're gonna oh should we pay
off this debt what you need is
information and wisdom and Rachel it was
so wise to tell call a tax professional
today don't sit there and just spin out
on I don't know what should we do I
don't know
just hire somebody go get an accountant
some of the best money you will spend in
your life is to get a tax professional
with you and does that make sense and
you're going to get some very clear
information about what your next steps
will be
yeah and we actually reached out to one
that we found through your website
instead of using the same a lady that we
worked the last couple of years so we
did reach out to one of your guys's
trusted tax professionals and so kind of
gave him a rundown of what we had going
on and so he said he was going to look
into tax law and everything for the last
couple years and just kind of see what
would benefit us the most but yeah my
husband was like well let's wait and
then I was like well let's can we use at
least half because I don't you know my
assumption is We're not gonna have to
use all of that depends I would do not
want to owe the government money
yeah
um and then you guys need to have the
discipline Abby because you got 85k in
credit cards personal you guys have just
been all over the place and that's not
to shame you but it's like we got we
gotta we gotta straighten this up right
we're pulling money out of the market
we're we're in this mess and so you guys
together need a really solid plan and I
mean like I would go detailed detailed
and to say okay we need an answer from
our tax professional by uh February 20th
on February you know um 28 I was gonna
say February 30th February 28th uh we're
gonna be uh putting money here there and
there like I like I want it down to the
dates and and I want you guys having a
plan that is so shored up that you can
look down and see on a sheet of paper
this is exactly what's going to happen
these are the dominoes that are going to
fall and we know exactly what we're
doing to knock out the stead you guys
make great money
um and and to budgets
um and if you guys have you guys gone
through Financial Peace University
I just bought it actually okay great um
I just bought it so like sit down
together and and do that yep I think
that's great and and do a budget maybe
for the first time ever do every dollar
uh but you guys you know you have been
scattered is what it feels like and so
yeah I'm glad you called because I'm
like I really want you guys to make
progress because you can you know you
guys are smart yeah you're smart you can
do this we are you know I'm I'm trying
to work extra hours at my job and then
he's also took on a second weekend job
awesome awesome you know you're ready
for it yeah picking all those yeah we're
taking all those steps and we know that
it's going to be a short-term sacrifice
I love it from gain and so great job
we're doing I just one tax question I
had and so now we're gonna Buck her down
and get gazelle intent that's right
excellent I love it Abby so John this
has been really a common thing this is
you know we did our Building Wealth
events around investing because this
time last year it was like the real
estate market people were freaking out
and now it's this market and we cannot
stress enough you guys
I don't care how much the news is
barking at you I don't care what your
family is saying on Facebook
people that are wealthy long term that
actually build real wealth not like this
Flash in a pan but long-term stable
wealth one of the the second thing that
they say is most important out of our
millionaire study is investing
consistently regardless of what the
market is doing Warren Buffett says to
be greedy when those are when people are
fearful and be fearful when people are
greedy and Grady's not a great word but
it's it's a powerful metaphor because
when people are jumping on like crypto
and all these new things and they're
like they didn't get in getting getting
in be cautious and then when people are
freaking out that's when you get in
because you guys when the market is down
it's on sale and people that build
wealth they are in it consistently and
when it starts going up again which it
will we believe in the American economy
enough to know that it will they they
make all those gains as it's going up
they make all that money and everyone's
sitting on the sidelines tries to jump
in then when it's going up so wealthy
people stay in consistently you guys
stay in the market don't cash out don't
slow down your Investments if you are
out of debt with a fully funded
emergency fund you find that 15 we're
doing Roth IRAs right now I just signed
the DocuSign literally today I'm like
we're
invest invest invest invest yeah we've
upped our investment too in our house
[Music]
we've been doing business at Ramsey for
more than 30 years by now we're a
well-oiled machine but it wasn't always
that way yes we've always had a vision
always had determination and a drive to
help people but what we didn't have was
one central place to access all our
numbers so that we could get further
ahead or quickly see when we needed to
Pivot we were always jumping back and
forth between different systems and
spreadsheets so when netsuite by Oracle
helped us Wrangle our Revenue inventory
expenses and more into one place it was
a game changer and netsuite's number one
Cloud Financial system can help your
business gain the same visibility
because businesses thrive on timely data
and netsuite's real-time analytics can
help your business have immediate access
to your numbers daily so you always know
where you stand and you can move quickly
so go to netsuite.com Ramsay today and
set up a free product tour that's
netsuite.com Ramsay
[Music]
thank you
you know the feeling
you've been on a few awesome dates with
a person things are getting a little
more serious and suddenly your brain
stops working you can't figure out what
to talk about next and then you all sit
there and just stare at your phones and
then you order another appetizer and
things get weird and then you bring up
your stepmom or something and the whole
thing just falls apart and things get
stupid and awkward so fast listen deeper
relationships happen when you have real
in-person conversations I saw the phrase
Rachel the other day digital intimacy
yeah
I just almost died
um listen deeper relationships happen
you have real in-person conversations
and get to know the humans behind the
profiles the ones or if you're already
with somebody long term like they're
sitting right there on the couch next to
you that's why I created questions for
humans you're gonna spend time laughing
together learning something unexpected
about each other I've been married for
more than 20 years when Sheila and I
were coming up with these questions like
my wife and I we're you know we were
doing the questions back and forth I
found out that stuff about her that I
did not know really and it was weird
it was super weird
for reals
um You're Gonna Learn unexpected things
you're gonna build deeper and stronger
relationships like humans together in a
room
weirdos or robots
not even like Chad gbt it's just listen
it's just humans talking to people and
while you're working on building your
relationships maybe you also need help
with other things holding you back from
your goals you can pick up my latest
book own your past change your future
and learn the steps to how to deal with
old hurts and ask yourself that
terrifying question what are we going to
do next all right so go to
ramseysolutions.com store to get
questions for humans and own your past
change your future today all right let's
go to Janelle into Como Washington
what's up Janelle
hi what's up
not a whole lot I'm doing pretty well
how are you guys excellent excellent so
what's up how can we help
um so I kind of have a
um
please pause the babysit because we
found out that we were pregnant yeah all
right congratulations yeah so we were
starting on baby step 3B we completed
three in uh October and so we've been
piling up money
and uh I find myself feeling like I want
to keep moving forward but we're in a
pause and so just kind of want to make
sure that we're doing things kind of in
the right order I guess yeah it's a
great question we usually honestly
Janelle say to pause baby steps one
through three so you guys are on 3B so I
mean if you want to just keep you're
going to keep pilot money do you have
the cat or the cash for the down payment
in 3B
not yet no that's where we were starting
we were starting to save that up okay
perfect so either way you're just saving
money right you you could quote unquote
say we're pausing and just piling up
money
but also you're not going to probably
get your down payment
in the next few months right no probably
not it'll be after the baby comes is
when mathematics
perfect so either way it's just you're
just naming it something different right
so you quote unquote say we're pausing
and just piling up money or you could
just say we're just piling up money for
maybe step 3B which is what you're doing
okay does that make sense
you can rob from the 3B fund if it gets
to it right yeah yeah if something
happens and you need some extra cash yes
yes you you could take from the 3B funds
for sure and for everybody listening
okay they'll label it as 3B yes yes
you're doing great Janelle you are
awesome
what do you do
um due in June awesome is it the what
number is this for you guys
this is our first oh congratulations I
was about to say this has to be your
first because it's like what are we
label the envelope yes we're like we're
like super planners both me and my
husband he's more of the geek but it's
nice that's so great so great the
beautiful thing about having a kid is
for super planners is you get to learn
how your plans don't matter
kids don't care about your plans when
you think you have control over life
have a kid and be like wow I really
don't and if you think you I remember
when Hank was Hank was born after about
um three or four years uh the air my
arrogance was so insane I told my wife I
was like what are we doing we're amazing
at parents everyone else is terrible
everyone else is is like sucks at this
and then the second one came and then
Josephine shows up and I was like I I
don't know what we're doing like this oh
our first Amelia I think I was like
should I write a parenting book I told I
told my wife I was like why are we why
are we professors this we should just
write our books and go on the road too
without a parent we're so good at this
and then
number two which I can say I'm the
number two of the family I am too so we
can we can we can speak for those middle
kids oh man I know so I was wrong all
right let's go to Craig in West Palm
Beach oh yeah Craig we're coming to you
but real quick for the listeners out
there so yes when you're doing the baby
steps we do say pause your debt snowball
if you're paying off debt and you have a
big life change whether it's a big move
a job change you're pregnant anything
like that but you can pause your debt
snowball and pile up cash to make sure
you have a good big pile of cash in the
bank for those big Transitions and then
after it happens you know after you have
the baby mom's home baby's home
everyone's good press play take that
cash and throw it at the debt snowball
so that's what Janelle was that's what
she was asking all right now we'll go to
Craig in West Palm Beach what's up Craig
how we doing
hey how you doing good good good what's
up
um so I've got we have a mortgage at
three percent fix there's about a
hundred and twenty three thousand left
on it and I also have student loans
of about 49 000 locked in at 1.75
percent
and we're my wife and I make about 160
total
uh and so I noticed that we're we're
we're stuttering out I guess or whatever
you want to say with the taxes uh the
tax benefit of you know deductible
interest for the student loans and I'm
wondering what is smarter to put any
extra money that I can find toward to
try and pay down it doesn't matter I
would take the my notes
and my spreadsheets on the interest rate
differentials and I would flush them
down the toilet
okay I would not look at that one more
time I would just simply okay look at
I owe the government money I need to get
that paid off
and then I've got to pay my house off I
gotta get emergency fund I'm gonna pay
my house off and with the money you guys
make emergency fund how much do you have
a roof how much do you have in that
uh well well we don't we don't have the
new roof yet it's got to come up and
we're getting estimates around thirty
thousand how much is in your emergency
fund
uh we're doing okay we've probably got
about so well honestly like 35 40. okay
um but we've been saving very hard
because we knew the new roof was going
to be a problem you know it's Florida
being the homeowners insurance and
everything just went up too so yeah of
course we're we're kind of okay ish
um this one's Gonna Hurt yeah and we'll
we'll start saving again but I just want
to know like I've got to do something in
my my daughter's 14 and she's gonna be
going to college pretty soon yeah we're
gonna have to do that and we can't
afford to for sure so correct yeah so is
the student loans is that the only other
debt you guys have
so yeah so the we always kind of lump in
Consumer Debt to paying that off first
and then after the roof is gone I would
bump up your emergency fund to three to
six months of expenses
and then are you guys saving for
retirement
yeah yeah we are saving like we we do
the Roth IRA every night we've been I
don't think I've put anything in last
year okay
um well I would honestly I I would pause
that Craig yeah just pause for a year or
two until or not even a year I mean just
a year probably you'll get this 49 000
paid off quick if you guys really take
your income and say hey we're going to
live on nothing and put all of it
towards the student loan pause
retirement pause everything until the
student loan is knocked out once it's
knocked out then that's when you bump up
that emergency fund and then press play
on your Investments and say okay yeah
we're gonna go back to invest 15 of our
incomes retirement and then your
daughter's College comes next after that
okay so that's the order that's called
the baby steps uh if you hold on the
line Jenna will pick up and um we're
gonna give you guys a membership to
Financial Peace University for a year
and this is a great class to go through
Craig are you married
I I am yes great perfect okay so you and
your wife sit down and go through this
class because I you know in a two-minute
radio call we can only just give you
that information really quickly but I
want you guys to absorb this because it
is it's a proven plan that walks you
guys are perfect for it because it's
exactly everything you're wanting to do
and do it in the right order with the
goal of of at the end being debt free
controlling your money and Building
Wealth and being generous and the
quickest way from point A to point B to
do that is the baby steps and so you'll
learn all that in Financial Peace
University so thanks for calling all
right we'll be right back right here on
the Ramsey Show
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
this is the Ramsay show I'm John deloney
joined here by bestselling author Rachel
Cruz give us a call at triple eight
eight two five five two two five all
right Rachel
um
I know you know this because we talked
about this off air a lot I am a huge
consumer of tick tock and YouTube
particularly
um uh viral videos you love the viral
videos I love Tick Tock Sensations
um and so there's one making the rounds
right now
um with Sebastian George Georgia
George you that's right
um 25 year old Finance YouTuber
just that phrase that phrase didn't
exist like three years ago into all of
human history a 25 year old Finance
YouTuber told his followers they should
be able to easily afford a two hundred
thousand dollar car he called it literal
literally Pocket Change
um hey we have a clip for it we're gonna
show the clip okay let's show the clip
let's roll it if you're a guy in your
20s and you don't have a Lamborghini you
should actually sit down and have like a
serious discussion with yourself as to
why you don't have a Lambo yeah because
it's I realize now that it's so
incredibly easy and there's so much
money out there and 200 Grand relative
to what is out there in circulation and
what you can grab especially now with AI
tools that you can leverage like never
before 200 Grand is Trump change
200 Grand chump change which as you can
imagine he's just gotten blasted
um for being a privileged whatever
whatever whatever turns out his
um parents immigrated to this country
when he when they were teenagers he was
raised in a very low income and worked
at Taco Bell he is literally
if his if his story is to be believed
earned this money yes yes self-made and
literally started from nothing and
probably in the tech world you know
whatever he's doing job-wise I don't
even know
um yeah has made this okay so I have
like just polar opposite reactions in my
head because at first I'm like dude like
who what no yeah like that's no no
that's not chump change like 200 000
because you look at what the average
American spends I mean and we deal with
you know everyday people on the show and
it's like man you know they they're
they're living paycheck to paycheck and
all of it so household income
yeah that's my that's like my first
reaction but then you hear a story and
you're like man
you know immigrants that come to this
country
uh they say you know build wealth and I
don't have the stat right but I think
it's like five times faster if they come
legally versus just someone that's born
here in the States because that because
that's the other that's the other
argument is I'm like okay so he sees
opportunity he comes he sees it
everywhere everywhere and he's like how
could you not be making so much money
because there is so much out there to be
made to be made and there's so much
opportunity of of course you're going to
be making a ton because you can right
like that's his mindset uh so when I
when I worked at universities for all
those years I
um all my International students uh I
would always like do sessions and we
would hang out we'd have lunch together
and we would they were part of my
classes
it was always amazing to me how my
International International students
that came in they were so wide-eyed with
opportunity they just saw it everywhere
it was it was wild and they they
inspired in me I remember 10 15 years
ago
you're missing this whole thing right
you are so focused on getting this one
job with this one salary so that you can
meet some sort of internal and I was
just missing opportunity after
opportunity after opportunity and so it
really it inspired me years ago
um that uh they just gave me a new set
of glasses with which to see the world
so I see this and you got a guy whose
parents immigrated over here as
teenagers grew up with almost nothing
and now yes I would tell him if he was
my friend don't say that out loud all
right I don't know I know don't say that
out oh you sound like an idiot but but
also
man if you were able to sit down and see
the world and say there's so much
opportunity what do you like get up and
go find the opportunity go make it
happen go make it right it's inspiring I
mean in that sense right and and again I
hate that a Lambo was his example I wish
it was like go get a 200 000 house
they're like you know what I mean
something that feels a little give 200
000 away but it's it's a sentiment out
there is
isn't true I mean it is it's inspiring
it I mean when you think about it that
way you're like man what else can I be
doing but I think too we can get in that
mindset of like just pilot money pilot
money pilot money make more make more
make more make more make more but there
is more to life than just that equation
right and so
um all that plays in as well so there's
there's many different angles I think
this this kind of story for me is is as
important as somebody like cam Haynes or
David goggin somebody who's running
marathons every day or running 200 mile
races whatever
the average person's not going to do
that but when you have these
pacesetters out there who are doing
these amazing things it makes me when I
want to skip my 30 minute workout or my
60 Minute Workout in the morning because
I don't feel like it or I'm too tired I
can't today
yeah I can yeah you know what I mean
yeah right or I just can't get ahead
it's just too hard I just can't find the
job
yeah you can right there is opportunity
somewhere and it might be doing stuff
you don't like like working at Taco Bell
I spent four years at Burger King like
it's not my it wasn't my dream job yeah
man I learned a lot of great lessons and
learned how to love and take care of
people even while asking them would you
like fries with them right
um and so yeah it just reminds me of
that abundance
um scarcity mindset man it's just
everywhere and if you change that
mindset it it does have it doesn't solve
your problems money doesn't go in your
bank account but you begin to look at
the world a little bit what is it Henry
Ford if you think you can if you think
you can't you can't you can't yeah or it
is what it is right so like what you
believe you know does have fruition in
your life I mean there is power to that
so you gotta go make it happen so yeah
that's great anyway Sebastian
just in the future just don't get on the
internets and tell people that 200 000
pocket change and thank you for
inspiring us to see the world a little
bit differently that there's an
opportunity everywhere
um all right let's go to Zach in
Shreveport what's up Zach
hey guys thanks for taking my call you
got it what's up dude hey so I'll start
with my question
um and then I'll give you a little bit
of background uh so my main question is
am I putting too much money towards baby
step six
um so me and my wife uh we combined
after taxes make about 1 130 a year our
mortgage so we're completely debt free
um so we're four five and six right now
um and our mortgage is about 1700 a
month
um and only about 300 of that 400 of
that is going towards principal every
month so I've been trying to to put as
much money as I can towards the mortgage
um you know anywhere from three to five
thousand dollars extra a month
um and so my question is you know should
I be kind of not putting that all
towards that and putting it maybe a
little bit more towards you know
something like fun money or uh you know
maybe upgrading my wife's car in the
next year or so
um
probably all the above Zach I mean in a
way so are you guys I mean we say baby
steps four through six is kind of just
that like okay yeah you can take your
foot off the gas
and just breathe a little bit and that's
when margin comes back in
um and but I also think it's very
dependent on the couple's personality
there are some couples we meet and
they're like I don't need any lifestyle
I don't need to up my lifestyle at all
like we we're good we could still just
live how we're living and throw extra
the house get it paid off crazy soon and
and we're happy with that some people
are like oh thank God I'm out of baby
step three and like finally I we get to
plan a vacation and enjoy life and we'll
paint on the mortgage and we're working
on that so where would you guys be on
that Spectrum Zach just as a
um from a personal note you and your
wife
yeah I'd say we're kind of um in between
I I think I was always kind of you know
wanting to buy new things until I
actually found you guys I uh I sold my
Camaro and so I've totally changed my my
Outlook on money
um and I think my wife is very much on
board
um and so you know we we live well below
our means um but you know we I want to
be able to to put money towards the car
but I guess maybe it's an emotional and
mental thing inside of me that's you
know seeing a thousand dollars every
month going towards interest on the
mortgage and it just kills me yeah I
hear that totally is the car is it
needing to be replaced are you guys just
one upgrade because you can
yeah so I mean she's got a Prius so it's
I mean it's got 170 000 miles on it so
it's uh you know it's getting up there
but it's still running great so you know
eventually we'll want to upgrade a car
and we're actually putting money into a
super fund specifically for that okay
well Zach if the if from what I got with
the math you could have this paid off in
18 months I mean pretty cool so I would
I would just go ahead and pay it off do
what you're doing and then go back and
say hey let's replace the car and
everything after the mortgages pay off
but either way you're good but you can
do it yeah I'm weird about I'm worried
about death so anyway hey this is
another hour in the books thank you
Rachel thank you guys in the booth and
thank you Jenna hey thank you America
for listening we'll be right back on the
Ramsay show
foreign
hey it's Rachel Cruz if you love this
show and want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we have a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you trending and
helpful articles and tips on following
the Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramseysolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsey show where America hangs out to
have a conversation about your money
your marriage your work your life I'm
John deloney joined here by Rachel Cruz
best-selling author and good friend we
are taking your calls on just about
everything triple eight eight two five
five two two five is triple eight eight
two five five two two five let's go out
to Gabriel in Pensacola what's up
Gabriel how we doing
hey Jed how are you good good man what's
up how can we help
good thank you
um so I am on baby step two I am just
over five thousand dollars left to pay
off um but I'm starting College in the
fall and I wasn't able to get any
scholarships or anything so my only
option at the moment at least that I
know of is to go in more debt to
actually go to school so I was wondering
what you guys recommend to do
not that Gabriel how old are you
I'm 21. 21 okay where uh what are you
studying
uh I'm going for worship Ministries
okay
how much is the school you're going to
per semester
it's 10 000 a year 10 000 a year okay so
five grand what how much do you make a
year
uh just over 30 to like 35 I okay I'm
not really sure exactly yet okay perfect
so Gabriel what you're gonna do is get
another job make some extra and cash
flow that five grand for the fall
semester or you're gonna sit out the
fall semester and it's just called
deferred enrollment it's just think of
it we think of like college you're
starting in the fall he's got till Jan
you you have like nine months don't you
Gabriel no I'm just saying if you don't
make it then you don't make it right
yeah yeah that's fair that's fair
um there's this idea of let me just say
this out front do not go into debt for a
worship Ministry degree
okay okay what I'm telling you on this
sink in on the back for any reason any
reason
but also when you know your future is
working
at a at a church or a non-profit right
like you and you are unable to say hey
this is wrong or I'm uncomfortable with
this because you have to make payments
to somebody else right you you trap
yourself
and I'm just telling you from a guy who
got a lot of student loans
um the back side of this is not it just
takes your soul from you man and I'm
also not one of those dude I am all all
in on higher ed like that was my career
I love working universities I think they
they serve a great public good so I'm
not even going to bash them I just I'm
telling you you're setting yourself up
and so Rachel's right if you really want
to go look at this like a car or a
guitar or a new set of pedals if you
don't have the money you don't just
borrow it you just don't buy it so
figure out a way between now and then
that I'm going to save up this money and
make it happen yeah Gabriel it's almost
this mindset it's this game you play
where you're like no you know you know
the only option is taking out debt well
that's not an option so just take that
away and say okay so now what do I need
to do to get five Grands by the Fall and
that's the great thing about it's five
grand you can do that go get it man if
you were talking about 30 grand for some
you know a private university or
something we would have a total we would
have for sure the deferment conversation
and say you'll probably have to wait out
a year you're gonna pile a bunch of
money you're gonna apply next year for
Scholars you know it would be so I'm
thankful that it's not
very expensive but you yeah you have the
time a hundred percent to save up and
pay for this thing I mean and I'd also
just sit down with the church where I
lead worship now and say
I would I'm asking for you guys to
invest in me in the same way I'm
investing in you and
um
see if they would help out as well yeah
um often employers will help with
extra education benefits if you sit down
and ask them so I would do that man but
hey take like I love Rachel love that
you said that take that off the table
it's not the only option it's not an
option at all
um what is an option is working really
really hard working several jobs getting
uh work study programs getting a job on
campus asking your church yeah working
for the college working for the
University yes there's there's a 50
different options because Gabriel I'm
telling you I'm telling you 25 year old
Gabriel is going to be like yes 21 year
old gay real sacrificed worked extra
paid his way through but now I have I
have the option to go take a job any job
I want right so if a church is is paying
you less but it's the church you really
want to go work for after you graduate
you get to because you don't have bills
you don't have anybody any money yeah so
it's it frees up so so much so your
future self
it's he's gonna be thankful I'm telling
you and I may have bought a guitar to
myself with student loans just don't do
it man just don't do it all right let's
go to Natalie in Kansas City what's up
Natalie how we doing
hey John hi Rachel thanks for taking my
call today it's a pleasure to speak with
you you got it what's up
well my question is we are on baby step
three and we have about two to three
thousand set aside and a separate
savings account we have about 20
000 in several different mutual funds
that are non-retirement uh one is just
the general account for my husband and I
and then the three others are set up for
our kids future with what they want to
do with it whenever they do or do not go
to college and my question is do we
should we take some of that out right
now to build up to our 20 000 for our
goal of six months of expenses for
emergencies or since the Market's kind
of down right now and I keep hearing
it's basically on sale should we just
leave it in there and just work
on cash flowing up to our emergency
front our emergency fund goal yeah it's
a great question
um how much you guys make a year
who we about
65 to 70 000. okay
um you know just in pure Ramsay gazelle
mode baby steps one through three it's
like all hands on deck everything and we
say cash out non-retirement Investments
specifically to pay off debt and then
when you guys are here for the emergency
funds
um to yeah that's that's a real option
so it's really for you guys what you
want to decide okay do we want to wait
another probably five six months to
build this thing up or today do you want
to cash it out put it aside and then
start working on retirement so I mean
honestly Natalie if I were you I would
want to keep making progress and
movement and because you're not gonna be
penalized because it's not retirement
they're non-retirement accounts
um you know I know it I know it hurts to
be like man it's on a down market so you
could even maybe split it 50 50 and say
hey let's take let's take some out and
then say you know in the next three four
months is our goal to have our fully
funded emergency funds you could do that
as well so it's it's how gazelle intense
you want to be
okay all right perfect I was just
curious about that so thank you so much
whatever it's worth Natalie if you and I
um if I was traded places with you I
would do that
um having had to I bought a new house
um I guess I'm two and a half years in
now and I wasn't a brand new house it
was new to me and had a great inspection
and everything was good and since then
I've had to replace a deck and a roof
and a front porch and an air conditioner
I would like to have that emergency fund
full I'd rather have the emergency fund
full now than have Investments and have
an Investments for whatever my kids want
to do in five or ten or fifteen years so
that's just me that's what I would do um
can use that for whatever it's worth hey
we'll be right back right here on the
Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
this is the Ramsey Show I'm John deloney
joined here by Rachel Cruz give us a
shout at triple eight eight two five
five two two five my two best buddies on
the planet John King and Todd showed up
today to see me and my wife surprised me
for Christmas it was my Christmas
present she flew my buddies in so it's
good to see you guys ma it's making my
heart full
he's good friends dude I know they you
should have them on they should come in
here I think that would be a terrible
idea tell tell a few stories I think we
will Dave works really hard to get the
show off the ground and running over 30
years and we can end it really really
quickly let's go out to uh Devin and
Seattle Washington what's up Devin
moving in June and
I'm a little stressed because of the
first time we were moving from an owned
house to buying a new house
and the thought of going back there
multiple times to try and find a house
is like really kind of stresses me out
so my thought was would it make sense
for us to sell our house here
and then rent an Airbnb out there for a
month
um while we're looking for a new house
I've done that
or even better rent an apartment or a
house for six months and get to know the
traffic patterns and the layout and who
lives where and what neighborhoods are
up and coming what schools and all that
kind of stuff yeah renting in general
Devin I think it's a great plan
especially in a new city for what John
just said I would look at what's most
economical right if it's a Apartments an
Airbnb might be I don't know maybe
expensive you'll need to price it out
but renting in general renting in
general for a year I think is is wise
that's actually what we recommend people
do because you're going to learn the
city and just what John said you're
gonna figure out okay where do we want
to be
um versus just doing a trip here or
there where are you moving
that's the thing is we're moving back
home so oh so you know the area yeah
yeah I think third years there so I know
the area really well that's the thing is
you know because we're trying to decide
that there's also training size we want
to get like a small mortgage because
we'll have a huge down payment coming in
and it's like do we buy a cheaper house
with cash or buy a nicer house that we'd
stay in longer
and get a smaller mortgage so it's just
all of that stuff has been kind of
stressful on us I like so when my wife
and I moved from Texas to Nashville I we
I I was terrible we didn't do it well
and and I take full ownership of that
um I would tell you and your wife to sit
down and write down on a piece of paper
the points that are stressing you out
the most
and the ones that you can put off for
two or three months after you get there
and get settled and let everything
exhale and you get through the closing
of your house and all the stuff in the
boxes and get it shipped out all that
stuff
get that done man
and if it gives your family you and your
wife peace to have a place that you walk
into and someone hands you the keys and
you're only going to move once and this
is your home do that too the key is is
to write this stuff down and get out of
your heads because she's gonna have a
picture of what this looks like you're
gonna have a picture of what this looks
like and that misalignment is what's
going to cause so much chaos and it's
going to heighten the stress it's gonna
it's gonna amplify stress that's not
really there okay and so whatever your
decision is I I if I'm you I would do
exactly what you just said I would go I
would call somebody with Airbnb and say
I'll rent it out for the whole month for
this price we take it and they'll
probably say yes because then they won't
have to turn it over four times and then
you can go ah check mark and then get
your stuff sent to a storage space for
60 days and then you got you you and
your wife can figure out where you're
gonna move that's what I would do
okay cool yeah I know thanks thanks it's
just it's been one of those things where
it's like
technically that increases the price of
the home by you know a couple thousand
dollars and there is no price on Soul
tax brother like I would rather pay a
couple thousand extra dollars and be
able to breathe and still be married
for most people it's the it's the
largest financial investment that you're
going to make so any amount of just like
oh taking a deep breath slowing down
you're good you're good you're good you
know if you can have a little bit of
margin in that space even if it's for
that month
um it's gonna be worth it because you're
good you guys you guys are wise you're
smart you sound like you're on top of it
you know what you're doing
um so yeah just taking a little bit of
time is is totally fine especially with
the you know you're not buying a five
thousand dollar used Honda right I mean
like this is a home so it's like you
want to take your time with it and make
sure that it's exactly what you guys
want mathematically it works in all of
it you have more peace when you just
slow down
okay all right thank you very much for
your advice absolutely thanks for
calling
all right let's go to uh you know what
Rachel
you had something go viral on Instagram
the other day tell me about it oh yeah I
did a uh a real like a where you like
dub the you know your voice over talk
you're talking to me like I'm like I'm
seven no I'm trying to I tried to get
the words where I'm like I don't even
know what it's like I don't know how the
internet's working I don't know uh and
it was a Taylor Swift song it says
horrified looks from everyone in the
room and so and then you put on the real
like what is the thing you say that
people just look at you crazy so I put
of course when I when you get married
combine checking accounts because it's
the one piece of advice I put out there
and everyone's like oh my gosh and of
course I was like oh my gosh and they
they got so mad do we have the clip
James
oh there's no sound
oh they can't do it for licensing
reasons oh man okay
yeah sorry t-swift don't want to mess
with you you're good go on go into our
teeth with don't worry about me uh but
she's not yeah she's just don't worry
about me
but yeah but the the hate is the the
despise of this piece of advice is still
out there John I mean and it always will
be when you say it out loud what what's
like and you have tons of women who
follow you like hundreds of thousands
they come after they literally come
after you they get so many they're all
team right now until you say you need to
share your account they get so mad so
the one is a very more fear-based but is
a reality for a lot of people is divorce
that if you combine all of your money he
can take it all and then you have
nothing you know you have no autonomy
you have nothing so it's this future
fear of if a divorce and then the other
one is
yeah we just fought all the time so now
that we have separate accounts we don't
fight anymore
and I'm like yeah because you're not
talking about it yeah you just duct tape
over the cancer and let it I mean I'm
like oh my gosh so those people I'm like
okay the fight you're avoiding is the
fight you need to have right like that's
what you should be fine like yeah you're
just sweeping it under the rug and so
what is under that so that's always my
push and so the quote-unquote easy way
out is just like I'll just have my money
he has his money and we can just live
our separate lives financially and just
go we don't have to ever have a hard
conversation about it there's never
going to be conflict we're going to just
run these two lanes and you know and you
know this John I mean you have even all
the studies on it but
when you combine your finances it's more
than just combining bank accounts it is
combining your life you are saying to
someone
I am with you in this in this marriage
that we are one in every aspect of Our
Lives including our money and so you
have to have the conversation about who
are we going to be yeah what are we
where do we want to live what kind of
Life do we want to have where are we
going to go on vacation what kind of
cars are we going to drive what do we
want for our children or do we want to
not have children you have to have all
those conversations and if you keep
Separate Lives
you just you're just glorified roommates
who hook up right I mean you're just not
in this thing together together no yeah
there's a read the date the research
data came out
um the the couples are happy yes couples
are happier when they're on the same
page
well we've said before like if you can
share a bed and share genetics with your
yeah if you could grow a kid running
around you should be able to share your
money and I get that it's hard and I get
that you know Opposites Attract and and
all of it and if and of course the
asterisk is always if you are in an
abusive relationship or there's an
addiction I mean if there's something
there that you need to protect yourself
that is one thing right but for majority
of couples out there it's just this
whole idea of oh I'm just gonna have
mine he's going to have his and we're
gonna just run these two separate lives
and it it trickles down into your
marriage you know what I mean like you
are a whole person you don't just have
the money side of you the way you
operate and the way you think and make
decisions is in every part of your
marriage and that includes your money so
being unified is is so key and the
couples that win long term with money
and win faster are couples that say we
are a team yeah we're gonna work
together I love it love it love it hey
triple eight eight two five five two two
five if you're mad at Rachel because she
just told you to combine your income
give us a shout and we will tell you
that you're wrong we'll be right back
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
the price of eggs is making headlines
you know you're dealing with a wacky
economy
Rachel guess what we have in our house
chickens yeah I'm not gonna Flex that
we're rich but we have lots of eggs yep
yep you're one of those the chickens are
crushing but even news about layoffs
chicken prices on again off-again
recession crazy high interest rates are
no reason to give up on your money goals
we're here to give you a plan for your
money join us on the Building Wealth
live tour as we show you how to build
wealth and drum roll please and keep it
join Dave Ramsey George Campbell Rachel
Cruz and Jade warshaw in Indianapolis on
February 16th then Dave can Coleman me
and Jade warshaw in Austin on February
23rd and then we're going to go to Salt
Lake City with Dave Ramsey George
Campbell Rachel Cruz and Christina Ellis
and finally we will close out the tour
in beautiful Anaheim on May 2nd with
Dave Ramsey kin me and Christine Ellis
tickets start at 49 bucks or you can get
a four pack of tickets starting at 175
bucks there's going to be
um programs that going on beforehand me
and Ken do our show live I think Rachel
you and George you are going to do smart
money happy hour ah there's a chance to
mention the venue but yeah very quickly
it's just gonna be it's so fun it's fun
it's just Mayhem these events in the
fall they sold out completely they sold
out selling out yeah it's it's happening
the attraction is picking up on tickets
so make sure to get them if you're in
these cities or travel travel to the
cities too and um they get off the rails
when we all get together at the end so
it's a lot of fun go to
ramseysolutions.com events to reserve
your seats for Building Wealth live
let's go out to Alex in the NY suit
what's up Alex
hey how's it going John how's it going
Rachel thank you so much for having me
you got it man what's up
so uh this time last year
um I decided that I needed to make some
spending habit changes and um I decided
to start paying off some credit cards um
I have a total of 10
um I paid off eight I have two left a
little bit disappointed that a few of
them are still on my credit but my
question is uh while I was doing that I
was saving money and just last month I
put 6500 sorry 6 500 on a CD
um and I also had five thousand five
thousand dollars cash and I'm not sure
if I'm doing the right thing with this
money that I put aside you guys have any
suggestions how much do you have in
credit cards on those last two credit
cards uh I have about 2400
okay so if I were you Alex I would cash
out the CD
and I would pay off the credit cards
today
I would take the remaining
um money that you have and I would just
put it in a good money market account
um and start building up your emergency
funds of three to six months of expenses
and that's gonna be your jump start to
doing that and then your next step will
be to start investing fifteen percent of
your income into retirement so so for
CDs
um I mean yeah there's just no you know
rate of return certificates of
depreciation that's appreciation I know
well most of the time they don't even
keep up with inflation so yeah and I
just opened a money market account at
four percent the other day yeah just the
other day
yeah yes and you know and I would get a
money market account with check writing
privileges quote-unquote what they're
called so you'll get a debit card with
it so you can do usually up to like
three transactions a month if you ever
need to dip into it but hopefully you
won't have to because it's just for your
emergency fund and hopefully you want to
touch it
um and then and then yeah and then I
would start investing but I think it's
you know you did a great job of just
putting some money aside I just think
you can put this money to better use
than it just sitting in a CD
let me ask can I ask you what made you
not pay off the remaining two credit
cards and put this money in a CD
um well when I look back at my credit
and I saw that all the pain like the
credits cards that I pay for still on
there I was just like this is kind of
pointless so I kind of slowed down a lot
with that it's so don't let somebody
else's paperwork problems
keep you chained up
okay
like at this point you've decided you're
not going to borrow money anymore so
your credit score is kind of useless
because all your credit score is is it's
a it's a dating score for your
relationship with debt and you broke up
with debt you're done so I I wouldn't
lose any sleep maybe look at that in a
year
okay but I I wouldn't let that like
they're taking too long to roll their
stuff off or they're going to roll off
in 90 days or whatever their policies
are who cares dude I'm not letting them
guide my decisions and especially I'm
not going to hey uh here here's the way
I'll ask it the way Dave would ask it
would you ever go
to your credit card and pull sixty five
hundred dollars
off of a credit card like cash get cash
advance on a credit card and put that in
a CD
no okay pay your CD off
I mean I mean pay your credit card off
okay and then with the five thousand
dollars cash that I have should I just
leave it in my savings my regular
savings account that's what Rachel's
talking about yeah I would I know I
would put that in the money market
account as well yeah okay I mean have
some buffering or checking account you
know because you have that margin there
so I have a little bit of buffer there
but I would put yes everything into just
a money market account and start
building up that three to six months of
expenses for an emergency fund very cool
man all right let's go out to Lorena in
Toronto what's up Lorena
hi hi thank you for taking my call you
got it what's up
um so I've been listening to you guys
for the last two months um and maybe
step number two uh our take out taking
uh uh pay 18 000 a month now my husband
thinks that he should have a hundred
dollars allowance a week
what do you guys think about that
you're bringing us into a fist fight man
real cool what do you think about that
um okay here's here's the rule of thumb
when it comes to baby step two the
deeper you are willing to sacrifice your
lifestyle
the faster you're going to get out of
debt so he wants a hundred dollars a
week how much debt do you guys have
73 000. okay
and that's concerned with that that's
not that's not including their health
That's not including your house okay yes
and how much do you make a year
uh well
no both of you ww combined is 160
Canada has a lot of taxes so you bring
home eight grand yeah yeah okay okay
okay yeah so basically you only bring
home eight grand after 160.
yeah oh my sister okay sorry oh it
breaks my heart
I want you guys to look and say okay
that's an extra five thousand dollars a
year that could be going towards paying
off our debts right so you know and
people talk about you know do we put a
little bit of money in out to eat do we
still kind of like you know do some
stuff so the people that are just
gazelle intents and that's where we lean
where we're like get this debt out you
you sacrifice your lifestyle you there
is no just oh we're gonna just go have
some fun no no it is so intense you're
cutting out everything everything is
laser focused and you go go go go go go
for a short amount of time right I mean
you guys will be able to get this paid
off
um what within probably 18
months ish and so being able to look and
see 30 months yeah yeah but be able to
to map it out though and then say okay
what if we took on extra income but an
extra job and made some more so I want
you guys to really flesh out these
numbers because where it's just like oh
it's just 100 bucks a week pan that out
to say okay what is this really going to
cost us in the long run and be realistic
though about your budget too that is one
thing some people that get so gazelle
intent so like we're only gonna spend 28
dollars you know all groceries a month
and something and you're like no no you
got to be realistic about your life you
want your budget to work for you so your
kids are eating raw spaghetti yeah yeah
so be realistic but a hundred bucks a
month for fun money is not gazelle
intense it's 400 bucks a month for fun
money that's yeah I mean yeah 100 bucks
I'm sorry a week yes 400 yep and let me
say this Lorena
if
if you and him sit down and say hey
we're gonna forgo quote unquote fun
money
um and we're gonna make lunches here at
the house you're you're gonna have to
tell your buddies at work um and I've
had to do I did this years ago I would
just take my lunch when we went when my
buddies went to get chips in case there
was a bit I would take my lunch with me
which is embarrassing and absurd
um and by the way when they were my good
friends nobody said anything I mean it
was just is what it was you're going to
find that he's going to get frustrated
and he can channel that frustration
getting a third job getting a fourth job
I'm sick of living like this so I'm
gonna accelerate I'm gonna go make more
money than fine I'm not gonna just kind
of settle in I'm gonna go get rid of
this debt so I don't have to live on a
hundred dollar a week allowance man it's
a short 18 to 24 to 36 month pain Point
man to live the rest of your life
with peace we'll be right back on the
Ramsey Show
[Music]
welcome back America to the Ramsey Show
I'm Ken Coleman George Campbell joins me
this hour the phone number to jump in is
triple eight eight two five five two two
five our scripture of the day comes from
Colossians 4-2 devote yourselves to
prayer keeping Alert in it with an
attitude of Thanksgiving our quote is
from Tony Dungy even though we can't
always choose our circumstances we can
always choose our attitude in the
circumstances
uh though this weekend in the Ramsey
newsletter we've got an article about
how uh marketing offers and one-time
deals could be money traps well that
feels like George Campbell inspired
right up there uh while these brick
promotions may sound like a good way to
save money in the moment the word free
it's very tempting it's most likely a
money trap say it's not so George oh
it's soaking
some money traps may be more obvious
than others like timeshares but some
traps may be a bit more sneaky like no
money down plants listen we've all been
stupid with money which is why we've
listed 10 money traps for you to avoid
in this weekend's edition of the Ramsey
newsletter simply sign up at
ramsesolutions.com
newsletter to subscribe to our Sunday
newsletter to get the full list that is
ramseysolutions.com newsletter it's like
getting a Sunday paper but it's free and
in your inbox George did you ever did
your dad ever get the Sunday paper oh
yeah we said I'd sit there I'd go
through the catalogs I'd print out
coupons it was a joy yeah I will tell
you that it was only about six or seven
years ago that I finally got rid of my
Sunday night you can see it in the
bathrobe pulling out the old paper you
know really enjoyed it really enjoyed
all the sections really enjoyed it and I
used to get the USA Today delivered to
my driveway and I would uh slink out in
the uh in the full body length row we
don't want to offend any neighbors and
and grab it it had all four sections
yeah you can't show off those chicken
legs too early no that's an HOA it's a
bit much for anybody to handle so uh but
anyway missed that yeah when did it just
become not a thing anymore I don't know
they're still paper boys doing their
routes at 4 am I imagine I don't even
know if there's still a Sunday paper
it still exists I got some research to
do Megan joins us in Tallahassee Florida
Megan how can we help
hey y'all hey hey what's up
so my question is I am currently in what
I thought was my dream job and whenever
I was going to school for it I loved it
I was excelling all that good stuff I
graduated 4.0 GPA
um so anyway I'm in the job right now
I've had it for about six seven months
and I just feel like I'm kind of going
through the motions now and making like
mistakes in my job that I shouldn't be
and just kind of feeling like is this
the job that I should have and then on
top of that like the company I work for
a hospital and it just feels like
they're more about about the you know
getting money
then like patient care well that's
probably true sadly what is the job what
is the dream job
a certified medical coder and so this is
what you want to went to school for you
enjoyed learning and getting qualified
for it and for a season you really
enjoyed it
yes
but you've only been doing it six or
seven months so I'm just and I'm not
trying to pick at you I'm just truly
curious at what point did it become yuck
and suck instead of yay
um I feel like
maybe like two or three months ago
whenever I kept like being like Oh yes I
can take on more work I'll take on more
work I can do it aha
so yes now we figured it out
Megan you still enjoy the work
but too much of any one thing is awful
if I ate steak every day three times a
day it wouldn't take long for me to hate
steak am I right yes all right so you
have not
created a boundary for yourself and your
desire to please you're also brand new
or out of college you've been in the job
for just a few months and they keep
piling on and you keep saying yes I can
do it yes I can do it and now you're at
the point you're going Kim I can't do it
anymore
so all right great so here's the point I
wanted to get clear and you get clear on
what's really going on you don't all of
a sudden hate the dream job you aren't
all of a sudden missing details because
you just don't have it anymore you're
overwhelmed sweetheart
okay am I right
yes heavy I mean listen it's literally
like trying to get a drink from a fire
hydrant when a fireman opens that thing
up and that water is just streaming out
you're not getting a sip of water it's
just too much try not to drown right
yes okay so here's what we have to do
you're gonna have to do what very few
people have the courage to do
and that is go to your leader and go hey
I said yes I can do it
and I said yes I can do it too many
times and I went to school for this I
love this work but this is on me I said
yes that I can do it and I took off too
much I in order in other words I went to
the buffet and I got too much food on
the plate and I can't eat it I can't do
it I need your help
okay how does that sound
yes I definitely need to do that now
come up with a solution
so when you go back to them you have to
say I took on this much more work and
you know what that is I don't and you
got to say I need to cut back on this
much like I I said yes here here and
here and I shouldn't have so I need to
make sure we give this work to somebody
else because I want to keep doing this I
want to do a good job and they need you
you got it
yes you got it but hey do not be
confused this is not go get a new job
because all of a sudden I don't like
medical coding this is you took on way
too much and you're drowning and we need
to make sure that we can uh get our head
above water then the the enjoyment the
love of the work will come back
all right let's go to Bozeman Montana
Jeff is there Jeff how can we help
hey guys thanks for taking my call
um I'm just calling today uh I'm kind of
recently new to the Ramsey method and me
and my wife have been working on it the
last few months but just recently her
dad gave us the opportunity where he
wants us to buy his business which is
where I currently work and she thinks
that we need to wait longer and pay off
some more debt before we do it I'm kind
of hesitant and just kind of want to go
for it uh we he said he will finance us
himself and he'd be able to just pay him
off the profits that the business makes
um so it wouldn't really be cutting into
our current income at all and it is a
pretty successful uh business
so where's her hesitation coming from
obviously she wants to pay off the debt
you're saying it's not going to affect
your debt payoff goals
uh so part of her hesitation she doesn't
want us to be stuck with the business
and also we're expecting a baby this
summer
make life change
now how how quickly is this would this
takeover happen if you're paying him
from the profits are you Owners Day One
how does that piece work
yeah we would basically we would be
owners day one and we would pay him for
probably like 12 years are you guys
ready to take on ownership and that
responsibility I'm guessing it's more
time involved as well uh I'm already uh
running the business and I just got
promoted in the last couple months
so it would be a little bit more but not
a whole lot I'm already pretty much the
the head person in charge there what's
the structure of the deal how much is it
going to cost you guys and how long will
this take
uh it will take yeah about 12 years to
pay off and it's like a five million
dollar business so
um
so what's he charging you to take it
he wouldn't be charging us any interest
and so it's like
um like four or five hundred thousand
dollars a year
wow so what happens you know a few years
from now let's say the profits aren't
there and you still owe him millions of
dollars
sure
right and so that is a possibility he
has ran this business for 30 years so it
is pretty consistent but I mean anything
can happen
um so that is a possibility what's the
rush on doing this now can it be a year
from now you start this process uh uh I
mean he's kind of rushing us and then I
also am just like well I mean the sooner
we start the sooner we start you know
a savings account basically you know all
the money that we pay into that business
theoretically once we own it and are
able to sell it that would be you know
just more money that we would have I
mean it sounds like it could be a good
deal but I'm worried with your pregnant
wife stressing out about this and having
the debt if it's just we need to pause
and look into it more and get more in
writing what do you think Ken I think
that he wants you all to have the
business and I think it's okay for you
to go you know what can we just push
this off a year and then I'm all in uh I
think George's advice is right and I
think he'll be fine he's not going to
force you to do this now so just be a
man he'll be cool hey George good hour
always fun good show I want to thank
James and the crew behind the glass for
keeping us on the air I want to thank
you America this is the Ramsey Show
hey it's George Campbell if you like
what you heard in this episode and want
to know more about getting started on
the Ramsay baby steps go to
ramsesolutions.com and click on the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramsaysolutions.com and click get
started foreign
[Music]